[Music]
goosebumps is one of the best-selling
book series of all time
and this man is responsible for each and
every terrifying spine-tingling
horror-filled story
hi i'm r.l stein i write the goosebumps
books huh maybe he's not so scary i
actually started as a humor writer
well what do you know
in 1992 scholastic released the very
first goosebumps book but way before
that a young bob stein was into writing
jokes i started writing funny stuff when
i was nine years old all i ever wanted
to be was funny
when i came to new york i had my own
humor magazine and after 10 years i
thought gee i've done what i always
wanted to do i guess i'll coast the rest
of my life i had no idea what was in
store for me and then
things started to get spooky i had lunch
with the editorial director at
scholastic she had a fight with a y.a
horror writer and she said you could
write a good why a horror novel he said
okay no problem you got it and i went
home and
wrote this novel and it was a number one
bestseller i thought whoa wait a minute
forget the funny stuff and i've been
scary ever since that book marked the
start of r.l stein's horror writing
career and he eventually wrote an entire
series called goosebumps but it wasn't
an immediate success
they went out and they just sat on the
shelves they didn't sell two months goes
by three months nothing we figured
that's it didn't work out and then
something happened it's a mystery kids
discovered it somehow
nobody knew me really there was no hype
no advertising no publicity there was
nothing just kids telling kids it's just
you know one of these amazing lucky
things that happened
now after 25 years goosebumps is scaring
a whole new generation of kids it's a
really nice thing to be able to write
for different generations at first i was
shocked when adults started showing up
in my book signings i'd say what are you
doing here
say we loved you when we were kids and i
realized
i'm nostalgia to them i think you kind
of remember that tingle of fear that you
had when you were a kid
but with the success of goosebumps does
arl stein ever miss the chance to be
funny there's something weird with my
brain because horror always makes me
laugh it's the same visceral reaction
that's what i try to do in my books
people think if you're a horror writer
you're scary all the time and your whole
life is horror but i did my own late
night comedy show at upright citizens
brigade last year
are you doing one this year too
i'm waiting by the phone no one's called
me i don't know
i'm waiting
[Music]
that was it that might be my comedy
career
[Music]
it's a magic book art
i am one of those
a lot of strange artists who paint
pictures that people can't see
it's a discreet painting
it's only there when you know how to
unlock it
now you see it
now your dad
[Music]
my name is martin frost
i am what's known as a for edge painter
so i paint pictures on the edges of
books but are in such a way that they
become invisible unless you found the
books up in a particular way and then
you unfound the book and it vanishes
again
but gone
banished
because the gold has hidden the image
it is pretty much a british if not
english art form vanishing 4-h paintings
date back to about 1660
it really got going back in the 18th
century when it became quite popular
i was working illustration and i met a
fellow who was a footballer and he
showed me what he was doing and i like
that i thought that looks fun
i could do that
and that as i say was over 40 years ago
now
most of the work i've done has been on
antique books
i'll show you this one now here we have
here a large shakespeare it's a 1860
leather bound split double two different
images on one book
this is a book entitled desert isles
it's produced in the 1920s
this is known as a two-way double one
one one
and one the other
and both of them will be hidden
under the gold
i'm often asked by people and how long
does this take
how long is that piece of string if
you're working on a very small book it
will take you a few hours generally
speaking for a typical book of about
that sort of size a day and a half two
days if you're working on something like
a big bible it's not difficult to use a
week
the price
reflects the time that goes into it the
bigger bibles the big ones
six seven hundred pounds something like
that
ah
yes
another harry potter let me just open it
up
[Music]
gone
i found those quite satisfying as far as
i know i am the only commercial forage
painter working
and so long as my eyes hang on in there
and my hands i'll continue but if i'm
ever asked to describe myself i say
i'm a dad i'm a granddad and i'm a 4-h
painter
it's
that works for me
[Music]
[Music]
for me one of the hardest things about
having a friend incarcerated is the fact
that when i want to talk to him i can't
we're so used to being able to just snap
a picture and text it to somebody
we can't share that kind of information
with inmates
i am an artist
and i'm also the owner and director of
flipbooked llc
[Music]
when you're serving a sentence you miss
out on a lot of the day-to-day
activities
being able to see a clip of video of
your family and friends can make a huge
difference
but we can't share that kind of
information with inmates
the flipbooks i do take your video and
turn it into something tangible that you
can hold
basically four to six seconds worth is
enough to make a nice length of flip
book and when an inmate gets a flip book
they can see a brief moment into the
lives of the people they love
you can say a lot in 30 sheets of flip
book it's it's really cool
i've been incarcerated in state of
colorado for about 13 years
the hardest part of doing time is being
separated from the people you care about
they said they were going to send me a
gift and i didn't know what it was going
to be and i got a sheet of
all these little pictures and then i
understood what it was
this was the first one
it was a little dog playing in the mud
dog joy
pure unadulterated dog joy
it was a treat to be able to sort of get
a video you know in a way
i think it's easy to understand
why flipbooks can be so powerful for the
inmates but sometimes i feel like it
might almost be more powerful for the
families involved
being able to take just a few seconds to
capture some video that you know is
going to end up in the hands of the
person you love
is a very powerful thing
[Music]
what might seem like just a cluster of
small temples surrounding myanmar's
kuthadao pagoda is actually the world's
largest book
the kuthadao pagoda is a golden temple
built in 1857
but it's what lays around the
surrounding shrines that draws people
near
in each of the 730 white stupas stands a
marble tablet
combined these tablets make up the
entirety of buddha's teachings
written in the ancient pali language
[Music]
each tablet or page from the book stands
five feet tall and five inches thick
the tablets were once covered in
precious stools and gold ink
however after the british invasion in
the 1880s the site was looted and the
gold ink and gems were stolen
today the book is still accessible the
dense writing has since been filled with
black ink so the scripture can be read
for many years to come
[Music]
in castle germany for a limited time
only there is a replica of the greek
structure the parthenon
and it's made with over a hundred
thousand banned books
the parthenon of books is an
installation that is part of the
documentary 14 art show
the exhibit is from south american
artist marta minohin
her aim is to spark debate about the
issues of censorship and literature to
achieve that she has collected over 100
000 copies of 170 different books that
have been banned throughout the world
through various stages of history
the books include everything from mark
twain's the adventures of tom sawyer to
cecily von ziegler's gossip girl
it is not a coincidence that the
parthenon of books is located in this
german park as it was here that nazis
burnt over two thousand books by jewish
or marxist writers in the early 1930s
the books for this project were donated
by the general public and once the
installation is complete they will be
handed out to visitors with the hope of
inspiring readers for years to come
[Music]
you